it's over [ __ ] it's Wednesday
night do it die
[Music]
if your date if you're under 18 hang up
now you little [ __ ] I'm going
deep tonight we got the [ __ ] cookies
look at this
TKO we got purple ones we got a [ __ ]
old decapitated mushroom lid it looks
like [ __ ] what's the general that cut
his dick off this is old dick right here
what's his name no more the other guy
[ __ ] [ __ ] do the [ __ ] what it
was [ __ ] Oh Kate was Gemma Caitlin
Caitlin it's breathe drive and skate
with a little dick right there when I
freeze dry look at the helmet they're
gonna find this to one of years from now
in a cave from where then they gonna go
what the [ __ ] were you people beautiful
thing that's a beautiful
going deep tonight the house is on fire
[ __ ] diamond juice there you go
[ __ ] go Yuma get in the room to
get all the bad spirits on here it's
gonna be a good [ __ ] Wednesday night
just when you thought it was safe this
thing is on fire my thing is a [ __ ]
love for my safecracking days you can do
an entire show just blowing smoke in
front of it's not to make an appearance
[ __ ] you [ __ ] I even show my
finally ruin my head
[Music]
welcome [ __ ] uncle Joey here
what's crack-a-lackin' over there in
your world if you're under 18 hang up
now you little [ __ ] I don't want
no drug heads early here it's the uncle
Joey's show we're going deep tonight so
go grab one of your grandmother's antics
well coming into your [ __ ] living
room it's all over
we got everything tonight we got [ __ ]
patron Pablo Escobar's favorite weed we
got [ __ ] in classic OG we got this
[ __ ] from the Russians we got a bunch of
these look at this Bam Bam Bam Bam look
at this [ __ ] we're going deep - like
[ __ ] so tonight's your lucky
night you understand me no [ __ ] has
blue stars you're going deep for the
Soul tonight BAM never feel and feel
Joey's here this bag is empty from the
other end
they don't mean nothing we got other
things we got liquid acid we got
mushrooms we got everything tonight so
you were thinking about doing something
tonight's your lucky night [ __ ]
no anxiety metric medication
[Music]
it's a beautiful [ __ ] night to be
alive TKO in the house [ __ ] we ain't
[ __ ] around tonight look what else is
looking for Lee we're just gonna put it
in the thing like last week and just
fold it around a little more
there's no vitamin C don't forget this
one that's mixing into the table I don't
want you to think I Beach's [ __ ] yo yo
down on the head man a little funny
all-stars 1971 the cheetah
here we go Felicia by the way I did
23andme I'm [ __ ] Liberian West African
American Indian and Eastern Chinese is
[ __ ] and a little bit of Russian Jew
how's that for you [ __ ] they're
blowing deep tonight at least I am with
that mushroom that's different it's
close to your heart
and don't think just take a little piece
these are stronger than that you could
take like half of a half a cube not
don't be an ugly night be one side BAM
just like this when you're [ __ ]
around so I've been trying to tell you
that for weeks you're tough not you
you're tired shaggy she took a little
bit tonight's your lucky night
[ __ ] don't forget about me
Lexington Kentucky on Broadway tomorrow
night
bring the reefer the [ __ ] guns bring
it all we're going crazy there tonight
like we're going here [ __ ] tonight
you understand me was ready for a bun it
raise your hand raise your hand
[ __ ]
ready for bunk Italy you want the truth
let's do a patrol it's never right by
Thea
[Music]
Betty those he's ready for his first
bucket we're going deep tonight into the
murky waters [ __ ]
remember meditate let the belly button
hit your spine get all that air in
because we're going deep to it we're
drinking some mushroom water some bong
water with muchly juice we're not
[ __ ] around so that you ready let's
do it you got spots nobody's home today
you go crazy huh she's home she's back
already yeah oh yeah that was it
she was she had 20 minutes of work oh
[ __ ] there it is there it is there it is
suck that thing there it is that is the
seagull even getting up because you blew
it all out you know let's see [ __ ] up
you see I'm saying he's over there like
puff the [ __ ] up magic dragon is gonna
have to do another one move what escape
the sides
[Music]
where he goes
ready for gold let's talking around Oh
God look at this look at this right here
he's going deep tonight he's going the
distance my cake in 97 there you go oh
[Music]
[ __ ]
tremendous you understand me just when
you thought it was safe deeply deep deep
deep deep well [ __ ] around tonight
what's the name of the festival if
you're not doing done this week make
sure you go to La Femme International
Film Festival in downtown LA
Felicia Mike at the Regal theater
Felicia Michaels will be down on their
per million on the movie [ __ ] pervert
all over the [ __ ] this her pervert
it's all the same
your [ __ ] always end up going
to jail [ __ ] Harvey Weinstein's
cousins and his brothers get in trouble
man [ __ ] yeah the Apple don't fall far
from the [ __ ] tree
all those little [ __ ] were men
are [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you have a
party by yourself are you gonna party
with a bunch of jerk-offs which one's
better the ones by myself always the top
[ __ ] parties you understand me I
don't want to see nobody I'm gonna talk
to nobody I will sit here to my ass
groans roots and smoked bong hits and
listen to music and not miss the [ __ ]
beat love it I'm ready for a desert
island I have a party in my head all
[ __ ] time I don't even give a [ __ ]
whatever you're thinking about I kick
can the [ __ ] less cuz I got my own
parade I'm hearing people yelling I'm
here with everything in my mind
[Music]
[Music]
there you go dog he's a SAP goalies
problem that [ __ ] that he's holding his
head look he's holding this this
[ __ ]
this kids a [ __ ] Savage he has the
control of an archbishop look that's my
boy that's called training no [ __ ]
Irish juice straight to the heart marine
style you know I'm saying from the
Marines when the Philippines they would
shoot the cows and just taking the
[ __ ] mushrooms is done to their
mouths
that's our [ __ ] marine eats Mustangs
you kick the cow in the stomach and you
say [ __ ]
so beautiful my college is a good night
for you to check in with us you thought
you were [ __ ] gonna do this and that
the Dodgers are winning right you
believe that now at the age of 54 I find
out I got a little Chinese and me I
[ __ ] up big four years and I knew
something was acupuncture works on me
the whole [ __ ] thing Chicago oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] that's gonna be a yeah it's a
small amount Eastern Asian who the
finals they could be like Filipinos like
jungle [ __ ] savages or something
[Music]
anyway look at this the Russians gaming
oh [ __ ] look at this goodie goodie good
huh what are you gonna do with this you
machine gun you little [ __ ] with this
can you imagine yeah more it'll go away
surely one night or you can pay somebody
a small 50 like Harvey Weinstein than
they rat on your techeuns lately oh say
you know Harvey Weinstein somebody like
this [ __ ] and they got like a co-star
they're all pissed off walking around
with tic tacs in that mountain now it's
a bad situation Doug oh please
Harvey Weinstein definitely on his ass
love licked and [ __ ] you just throw
hundreds in the air lick my ass holy
[ __ ] no actually he's Harvey Weinstein
you don't give you dick thing you don't
even valet parking it [ __ ] I'll let you
suck his dick and not even valet parking
me understand it at least validate the
parking Harvey
Jesus Harvey I think you suck my dick
there's no validation you know how is
that mushroom dust you smoke [ __ ] yeah
yeah you name it know it you grind down
those mushrooms and you smoke that [ __ ]
I took a look I took a little hit to it
because everything I gave you everything
mushroom juice gorillas biscuit now put
some mushroom dust in the ball do a bong
in that [ __ ] huh what the [ __ ] you
people think you're dealing I gave you
shrooms in a bowl I gave you a hash I'm
never Cup that's perfect see that
transmission fluid with a little handle
it
listen you want to see the devil you
contact your uncle Joey all right
[ __ ] until then don't forget
youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz is the
place to be we got the beautiful and
talented miss Felicia Michaels we got
the [ __ ] the original
we got Uncle Joe
the original christ-killers that's your
new shirt I'm down with the
christ-killers you'll sell a thousand of
those things the first day you get
thrown off the plane but you're so down
for those [ __ ] things the first day
yo on Broadway comedy club Lexington
Kentucky the [ __ ] dilemma starts
tomorrow night I advise you to [ __ ]
be there bring whatever the [ __ ] you got
[ __ ] bluegrass I don't give a [ __ ]
what you got that [ __ ] you make it home
what's in that whiskey you make it home
no the other one moonshine bring some of
that [ __ ] I haven't had a good moonshine
since prison
and I'm saying on the rocks you get a
little dizzy I bought your eyeball gets
red that all that moonshine is [ __ ]
horrible I'm gonna get you an ice cube
from Wellman everything those mushrooms
taste bad wait till you taste that
[ __ ] moonshine pruno Bruno I shall
[ __ ] you up in prison with toilet water
have you seen that commercial with the
Mexican dude with the Mexican dude any
loot the kick comes up some hi I'm
looking for a beer that's awfully clever
but not really and the guy from Sons of
Anarchy you know it Mexican dude gives
them a Tenniel's here take this I made
it in my own bathtub and the guys like
roughs he's like some [ __ ] what do you
call those Millennials the other ones
the hipster [ __ ] em anyway youtube.com
slash c / Joey Diaz let's get this party
started I'll see you in eight minutes
stay black